I'm a dietitian and I'm going to show
you some of my favorite healthy Stables
that I get at Aldi let's go multigrain
flatbreads with flax have 8 grams of
fiber and 9 grams of protein this seed
tastic bread from Simply Nature has
three grams each of fiber and protein
plus it's packed with healthy fats my
kids love this oat based protein pancake
mix it's great for making chocolate chip
pancakes on the Fly I love a good
chicken sausage and these have 14 grams
of protein each and they're super easy
to prepare this two good brand of Greek
yogurt is my go-to because it's packed
with protein it's not that free and it's
only got two grams of sugar each you
guys know coffee has a special place in
my heart and this cold brew from Khalifa
is delicious but I'm craving just a
little something something at the end of
my meal these little mini ice cream
sandwiches always hit the spot if you're
an Aldi Shopper let me know some of your
favorite products in the comments below